Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Los argentinos somos corruptos.
Somos así por naturaleza; está en
nuestro ADN, no hay nada que hacer.
¿Cuántas veces escuchamos estas cosas?
Y dije argentinos, pero podría haber dicho
cualquier nacionalidad.
Lo que está implícito en estas frases
es que somos corruptos por naturaleza,
que somos incorregibles
y que nuestros valores,
lo que pensamos,
lo que creemos como sociedad
e incluso nuestro comportamiento,
es inamovible.
Lo que está en nuestro ADN
no se puede cambiar.
No es maleable.
Bueno, no es maleable,
al menos, en el corto plazo.
Pero ¿será verdad que somos así?
Yo sé que responder esto no es fácil,
pero no hay nada que me frustre más
que las frases hechas sin evidencia.
A mí me gusta ponerle números a las cosas,
contrastar hipótesis, usar datos.
La respuesta a esta pregunta
no es la excepción.
Pensemos un minuto.
Si no fuera cierto que
somos incorregibles,
entonces los datos tendrían que mostrarnos
que hay ciertos eventos
en nuestras vidas
que nos transforman, nos hacen personas
más o menos honestas.
¿Qué tipo de eventos podrían ser?
Seguro que alguna vez escucharon hablar
de esta frase que dice que las sociedades
tienen a los gobiernos que se merecen.
Claro, en general, pensamos
que son los ciudadanos corruptos
quienes terminan eligiendo a políticos
igualmente corruptos que ellos.
Bueno, en parte, es verdad.
Digo, los datos precisamente
nos muestran que, en general,
en los países con líderes políticos
muy corruptos
también viven ciudadanos
que son muy corruptos.
Lo que yo siempre me pregunté es si esta
relación necesariamente significaba que
eran los ciudadanos corruptos que estaban
eligiendo a los políticos que se merecían.
o si en realidad era exactamente al revés.
Tal vez lo que pasa es que los gobiernos
y los políticos corruptos
con su comportamiento nos terminan
transformando a nosotros los ciudadanos,
en personas deshonestas.
Yo desde hace tiempo que venía intentando
probar esta hipótesis,
pero parecía muy difícil.
Para empezar, ¿de dónde iba
a sacar los datos para probarlo?
Hasta que un día, de casualidad,
estaba en México,
estaba leyendo, analizando los resultados
de unas pruebas estandarizadas
que dan los alumnos del secundario.
Me encontré con un dato
que me pareció espectacular.
Estaba la cantidad de chicos que
se habían copiado en las pruebas.
Tres semanas después estaba en México,
seguía en México.
Estaba desayunando, tomando
un café, leyendo el diario,
y en eso me entero de lo que en su momento
fue un gran escándalo de corrupción,
que me dio una idea increíble.
Ahí me di cuenta de que si juntaba
los datos de los chicos que se copiaban
con los datos de los alcaldes corruptos,
voy a estudiar la relación
entre estas dos variables.
¿Saben lo que encontré?
Cuando sale a la luz
un evento de corrupción,
inmediatamente, los chicos
se copian un 10 % más.
Va de vuelta: un alcalde desvía fondos.
Lo descubren.
A diez cuadras hay un chico
que está en su casa,
a la mañana mirando
las noticias en el noticiero,
a la tarde va a la escuela,
le dicen que tiene un examen.
Se da vuelta y decide mirar la hoja
del compañero de atrás.
Es como si el chico hubiera aprendido
en tiempo real del ejemplo
del político corrupto.
Claro, si el político al que le va bien,
que es exitoso, es un tramposo,
entonces hacer trampa
tal vez no esté tan mal.
El ejemplo de los líderes
afecta a nuestro comportamiento.
Por ejemplo, nos copiamos más.
Y también moldean nuestros valores.
Cuando descubrí esto
tuve sentimientos encontrados.
Me alegré porque al final no era cierto
que nuestros valores y nuestras creencias
y nuestras conductas estuvieran
totalmente talladas en piedra.
No es cierto que nacemos corruptos.
En todo caso, nos hacemos corruptos
y bastante rápido.
Después me preocupé.
Si la corrupción genera más corrupción,
¿cómo hacemos para romper
ese círculo vicioso?
Y ahí se me empezó a ocurrir
una nueva idea.
Si hay eventos que son tan significativos
que nos terminan corrompiendo
tan rápidamente,
¿no será que hay otros eventos
que nos llevan exactamente
en la dirección contraria?
La respuesta a esta pregunta se me hizo
mucho más clara varios años después
de un viaje que hice
al norte de Argentina.
En ese viaje estaba en Salta.
Estaba de vacaciones.
Me acuerdo que parando,
visitando un pueblo rural,
una zona que la recuerdo
como bastante, bastante vulnerable.
Yo pasaba todos los días por una escuela,
una escuela muy carenciada,
que era la única...
la única escuela del pueblo.
Me llamaba la atención,
hasta que un día decidí entrar.
Por curiosidad, me puse a charlar
con los maestros, las maestras del lugar
y de esas charlas, y en general
de toda esa experiencia,
hay dos cosas que recuerdo
hasta el día de hoy.
La primera es que la escuela
estaba llena de chicos por todos lados,
estaba llena de alumnos dando vueltas,
pero había muy pocos docentes.
Claro, les costaba muchísimo encontrar
gente que quisiera ir y trabajar ahí.
La segunda es que nunca
en mi vida, hasta ahora,
conocí a nadie que
disfrutara tanto su trabajo,
que estuviera tan motivado
por lo que hacía
como las maestras
y los maestros de este lugar.
Me acuerdo hasta el día de hoy
la frase de una de esas maestras
que me decía una y otra vez:
Para esto elegí ser maestra.
La vuelta de la vida me llevaron varios
años después a trabajar en Perú
en un proyecto que buscaba precisamente
motivar a los mejores profesores
a que quisieran enseñar en las escuelas
más vulnerables del país.
En Perú, igual que en Salta,
igual que en un montón de lugares,
estas escuelas son las que
mejores maestros necesitan.
Y, en general, no son las más elegidas.
Inmediatamente, me acordé de la escuela,
de la maestra y de la vocación
que tenía esa maestra.
Y se me ocurrió que una forma
de motivar y guiar a los maestros
a que quisieran trabajar
en estas escuelas
era simplemente recordarles, ahí,
en el momento de la decisión,
cuáles eran los motivos que los habían
llevado a elegir ser maestros.
Con un grupo de colegas investigadores
diseñamos una serie de intervenciones
muy sencillas que buscaban guiar y motivar
a los maestros en esa dirección.
Por ejemplo, a un grupo de maestros
los invitamos a que nos respondieran
una pregunta muy simple,
justo antes del momento
en el que tenían que elegir,
tenían que decidir,
en qué escuelas querían trabajar.
La pregunta era muy simple, muy sencilla,
se respondía en un minuto,
tal vez en un párrafo,
y decía lo siguiente:
¿Cuáles son los motivos que te llevaron
a elegir ser maestro?
Con estas intervenciones
logramos aumentar en hasta 13 %
la cantidad de profesores
que terminó eligiendo y trabajando
en las escuelas más vulnerables de Perú.
Ahí en Perú, la maleabilidad de las
conductas, en este caso de los maestros,
hizo que los chicos que realmente
necesitaban buenos profesores
tuvieran a los mejores que podían pedir.
Así de simple.
Las intervenciones y los eventos
que afectan nuestro comportamiento
y que moldean nuestros valores
pueden ser un arma de doble filo.
Por un lado, nos pueden corromper
totalmente como sociedad
pero, por el otro, nos abren
una ventana increíble de oportunidades
para formar mejores ciudadanos.
Los valores, las creencias, las conductas,
no están escritas en piedra.
Cambian.
Todos las podemos cambiar.
Yo por eso me dedico a esto.
Porque sé que con pequeñas intervenciones
seguro que podemos aspirar a una sociedad
más cívica, más cooperativa.
Y, por qué no, una sociedad mucho mejor.
Gracias.